joining me now for reaction is Newt
Gingrich former Speaker of the House and
a fox news contributor note it's so good
to have you back from Rome how are you
are you perpetually jet-lagged that's my
question
no no it's fun let's talk about what
they are trying to do the usual suspects
you know all of them you saw that
tedious montage Trump's not smart he's
dumb he's on intelligent he doesn't read
etc etc etc what's going on here well I
mean the same people who have been
passionately avoiding reality for three
years are now entering a new year
passionately avoiding reality you know
you know there's a whole series of these
things we're we're I'm working on a book
right now called Trump's America and
there's a whole chapter of how wrong
they are
I mean whether whether it's somebody
saying he couldn't possibly be elected a
number of people who said the stock
market is gonna crash the minute he's
sworn I mean you go back and you pick
these people up I have a standard rule
if I look at the Sunday morning shows
and all of the wonderful elite
Washington figures have agreed that the
sky is going to be blue
and my assumption immediately as it's
not because they're just there that
they're wrong so often so let's take the
case of the current and the other thing
weather-wise the news media loves living
in the kardashian age there is no story
too small no semi scandal too stupid for
them to not spend a day or two just
frothing about it so I mean you've had
the same experience Trump is actually he
was smart enough to beat 16 other
Republicans he was smart enough to beat
Hillary Clinton he was smart enough to
help Mitch McConnell and and Paul Ryan
passed the largest tax cut in modern
times he's been smart enough to begin to
put get federal judges in who are
solidly conservative he is smart enough
to have the largest deregulation larger
than Reagan largest deregulation in
history in the first year so somewhere
in all that you'd think maybe he's
actually smart and dumb people get
elected president of the United States I
mean truly dumb people I mean you are
the academic give me the dumb person who
has ever elected president warren g
harding buchanan you have to go back
aways yeah they're they're trying to set
up a narrative
of Trump as unstable mentally deficient
can't be trusted with a nuclear button
you're seeing pieces not just in places
like CNN if Brian Staedtler was had a
piece today about how the the salacious
details of that wolf book aren't
important more important is is that the
book suggests that Trump is unstable and
raises alarms about his fitness for
office you've heard this building really
but we heard it from corker we've heard
it from people all the way back to last
January frankly the bombs start falling
on Moscow in ten minutes
that was not Donald Trump that was
Ronald Reagan during a test of the five
minutes or ten minutes can you imagine
how the current media would have dealt
with that oh my god that was one of
Reagan's best lines it was a throwaway
baloney line and he knew it and so did
the Russians but what did Reagan do that
Trump doesn't Reagan let it all kind of
slide off his back he did not engage
with him it was a different time he
didn't have twitter they're both I mean
I think you said it well earlier Ronald
I actually do think and I thought I've
known nine presidents I think these are
the two best this will shock some people
I think Reagan and Trevor I completely
agree with you yeah not even close in
terms of actual effectiveness yeah these
are the two best presidents that I've
known starting back with Nixon but
they're totally different Brian Kilmeade
has a new book as you know on the Battle
of New Orleans and Andrew Jackson and I
keep telling everybody if you read kill
me his book if you look at Andrew
Jackson you begin to understand Trump
Reagan is this stunningly sophisticated
person who had been a Hollywood star he
really understood himself he really
understood the media and he had a
totally different style than Trump Trump
is a rough-and-tumble businessman who
never acquired any of Reagan's you know
style but who understands I want to get
that done that story about that police
officer or the firefighter with a 401 K
he gets in with the people I always
loved seeing him on the factory floor
putting his arm around some of that
that's that's the Trump I think we need
to see more of not and I like his tweets
I think his tweets are almost always
effective
so I like his tweets but getting invited
that Bannon says this Trump says this
they're friends they're not friends I
got to have you weigh in on Bannon and
and what's going on there I I can't
figure it out I don't know who's helped
by oh sure you can
Bannon is a person and we both work with
Steve he was a he was a very smart very
interesting student of what's going on
in America he he read his own headlines
many of which he planted
he wasn't the chief strategist Donald
Trump was harder than nominee before
Bannon showed up and Bannon had a
marginal impact in the fall campaign he
really that some levels he's almost
irrational you go into the Trump White
House and you think I guess I'll pick a
fight with Jared and Ivanka and then
I'll pick a fight with Don jr. this is
suicidal I mean these are the kind of
things where you have to say you know
are you just crazy then are you saying
Steve Bannon is insane well the
president said I think that he had lost
his mind and that may be a more
appropriate way to put it who's insane
has certain you know psychological
preconditions I what I do think is that
Bannon thought there's so many once said
to me the Tiger Woods caddy actually
thought he made the putts and forgot
that in fact it was helpful to have
Tiger Woods he didn't drive the car in
the last ban and thought that he had the
skills the Trump has well he might run
for president in the report so he could
think of running for president would be
fine he'll get you know three percent
and be part of the continuation I think
actually this experience probably
eliminates most of his support for them
John Cornyn senator from Texas said the
falling out with Bannon may be a good
thing for the Republican Party see what
I'm worried is the ricocheting baton is
a conservative populist I agree with him
on almost every issue frankly he is very
smart he is a student of history I don't
know what's behind these quotes I you
know I'm not going to get into that but
I don't want Trump to to take the Bannon
problem and take the lesson from that
being I'm not going to do these issues
that
you know that we agreed on together
because I think they are they weren't
good together I'm not saying Bannon was
Trump Trump's Trump I think Steve Miller
trying to be a mend fences here for
people that's not trying to good luck
first of all Stephen Miller is the heart
of love him right and he he has all of
bannon's upside and none of his down
Wyatt right he's there doing his job
every single guy he I think he probably
channels Trump better than anybody in
the country second I actually have this
is like Reagan I remember as early as
the summer of 82 conservatives going to
lunch at Heritage go oh my god Reagan's
selling us out I mean oh yeah I have
enormous faith that Reagan was actually
Reagan I have enormous faith that Trump
is actually Trump Trump actually
believes this stuff
he believes in deregulation he believes
in so I don't worry about I don't worry
about banning leaving as long as Trump
stage
sessions as a couple congressman meadows
and Jordan said the sessions should
probably step aside they might be time
for him to step aside what do you think
about that I think I think that attorney
General Sessions ought to have a very
serious review of what he's doing
because he has a department that has
enormous problems he can't recuse
himself from all those problems and he
ought to be if he was still in the
Senate he would be really angry at him
as Attorney General and I like Jeff a
lot and and I hope that he will decide
that he is going to clean house and get
the job done
now they're opening up a couple new
investigations so we'll see Newt
Gingrich love having you on my best to
your ambassador do you call ambassador
or best address what am i she's an
ambassador ambassador or it's no female
I will actually should prefers you
caller : please do